all right Briana yes Briana where'd you
grow up were you from originally
um San Fernando Valley and tell me about
your childhood you had both your parents
as a kid no I grew up in foster care
from 14 months old to 10 and I got
adopted at 10 and I got adopt into like
a she was a Catholic woman like a
schoolteacher like totally different
from my real mom who was like a
prostitute or like a heroin addict and I
like it you know so it was kind of like
like I don't know the bloodlines were
different you know we have very
different personalities
yeah yeah mm-hmm like gaming and how was
your how would you describe your
childhood uh foster care I mean it was
everything that you hear about it you
know like like all the bad stories you
know but at a young age I learned that
if I wasn't like unsure about a place
that I could like run away
so I ran away a lot in foster care what
was the worst thing you had to go
through sir
um there was this one family that wins
doses like he dose his wife with
whatever he had and he dose us like the
girls and boys and like you know like
have his way with us whatever and I was
like stuck there for like six months
because like he was told that I ran away
a lot so I had to be like escorted to
school and like all that [ __ ] like that
like it was [ __ ] up so a lot of sounds
like a lot of sexual abuse yeah did that
continue with other families I mean yeah
like I don't know a lot of it happened
when I was sleeping so like now like I
sleep like really deep you know like I
guess if that happens like when you're a
child and you go through that like you
to block it out like you fought it into
deep sleep like when you're sleeping now
so it's
sucks yeah when you're on the streets
yeah what age were you when you started
working the street I was 16 16 then
where where was that that was in LA
south-central south central big rock
mm-hmm yeah where do you work today
um well today like I I mainly like do
like calls like I don't really have like
a pimp I kind of just do my own thing I
mean I went from making like a couple
hundred bucks making like a couple
thousand bucks so that's way better yeah
but you work like in the valley as well
mhm yeah
that's a positive yeah yeah can you
worked with a pimp before um yeah but
like I said I ran away a lot so like
that only lasted for about a week I
really like listening yeah
have you had some bad things happen to
you
yeah this lifestyle yeah what kind of
stuff did you um I mean like getting
like jacked you know like getting beat
up getting I mean everything that you
can like grab my hair and like pull me
in the car like stuff like that like
it's you know [ __ ] up but you nobody
really thinks about that and it's like
you live that kind of lifestyle you know
you've been arrested before yeah I've
done three turns
yeah before assault with a deadly weapon
and GTA's and identity theft mm-hmm give
kids I do
how many kids one child one and where's
your Cruiser Trump um he's out in Palm
Springs I um I just got out last last
last April I've been off for a year for
the first time I have like no parole no
probation for the first time in like 13
years so that's cool like I got
fifty-fifty with his guardian but he's
like gonna be 11 in September so yeah
our drugs are part of your life yeah
what's what's your drug um I do heroin I
do crystal I do sure my daily that I do
pretty much everything xanax
all that good stuff and when did that
start for you I started doing heroin 13
years ago and I started it by snorting
it and then slamming it and smoking it
and slamming it slamming it
but do you what do you think helps you
to survive this lifestyle it's a
dangerous life right yeah it is um you
get depressed attack yeah definitely I
mean I take those in and like [ __ ]
annex a day I have a prescription for
them so that kind of like just numbs me
out you know that's pretty much right I
think keeps me alive huh
are you making money yeah do you save
money
barely I'm really bad at spending money
how do you think working the streets has
affected you or changed you um I mean
it's definitely made me learn how to
like fight for myself like I mean I
you've been fighting for yourself since
you were yeah you know like since I was
baby so it's like I grew up in the
streets like they like raised me to who
I am today and like I don't know your
entire life has been toughest outside
yeah definitely
yeah
if you could if you could change one
thing about what happened to you is in
your life what would it be well when I
was 14 months old my my mom was like the
main connect right there in San Fernando
Valley and she was like work like she
was like the main person and they had
like a stash house and it just so
happened that I was at that stash house
on a specific day with her friend and
that day it got like shot up like shot
at and like the bullet flew over my head
and went into his rib cage and like the
cops were called and they went inside
and found everything and that's what my
mom went to jail for like seven years
and everything me she when she got out
like she couldn't find me you know so
but I found her when I was 15 when I got
pregnant are you even able to stand back
and look at your life and say that what
crazy lifestyle this is or because
you've lived it
it's it's honestly just like normal to
me now like I mean like I don't it's
hard when like you don't have direction
and security and you don't know like how
to take the steps to get to like bigger
and better things you know it's just
just like a reoccurring circle that's
just going and going and going and going
like a hamster wheel afraid you go at
school um I actually got my GED when I
was um 16 so yeah when I was pregnant
you been in love before
yeah yeah gel comes in between
relationships so that's not really
something to think about
yeah and your your child you talk to
them sometimes yeah I talk to him every
night I pay I play PS ps3 with him every
night world war two or three I mean
World War three do you think your
self-worth plays a part in the decisions
you make in life
yeah um definitely I mean like you know
when you grow up like not really having
anybody to like love on you or show you
anything like you know you kind of just
like don't learn about that you don't
have that like
so it's like you don't really invite it
because you don't know what it's like to
have that so it's like when it is there
you don't know what to do with this so
it kind of scares you a little bit so
like you push away more yeah you never
had any role models - yeah exactly -
anyway what advice would you give to
some young girl who's got a similar
situation and she's considering doing
this kind of um go to school and get
your diploma and go to college and take
every chance you can get with somebody
that could help you yeah like I mean
I've been I've done three turns and like
it's really easy for a convict I guess
to go to school I just found out like a
couple days ago like that they'll like
take you through everything and like
pretty much everything's paid for and
everything and like I didn't know that
until couple days ago and I'm 26 and
I've been going to jail since I was like
18 have you ever had anyone in your life
who truly just wants the best for you my
son I think my son yeah yeah
where do you hope to be in the next like
five years or so um mm hopefully some
more different than where I'm at like
this is the first time in 13 like I said
13 years that like I have no tail or
like no parole and probation no nothing
so like it's like somewhat in a normal
life like I could have a normal life if
I really tried and really wanted to and
really try to get that you know like
because jobs like don't hire you you
know like convicts and you have
probation [ __ ] like that like but this
is the first time that I'm like not on
any of that stuff so so I told you I'm
26
no you still have plenty of time yeah
yeah
what would help you the most to change
direction right now um probably a detox
place to get clean yeah you're using a
lot of different drugs yeah I mean
heroin is like you know it's you become
a slave to it like you can't really
think about a job or like any kind of
life so and like you have to have
something like and it's you it's hard to
get money for that like you you have to
have it it becomes your first priority
right yeah exactly like more than your
child yeah like I mean like a couple
years ago I because I was using the
needle for like six six years or
something and I fell in love and the
person that I fell in love with didn't
like heroin or slamming and like I
remember I just got into a bad car
accident and he like let me stay at his
house and everything and like this if
one day I just like because I couldn't
move because of the car accident and I
was trying to hit like I just kind of
like broke down and started crying and
he like told me that he would help me
get off so like I did I switched from
slamming to smoking and like I don't
know that was a big thing for me like
cuz like I never stop slamming for
myself for my kid or anybody you know
like that wasn't an option
it didn't seem like what is your typical
day look like
um well going and getting as much money
as I possibly can and going and getting
a room and then the next morning you
have to check out and then you have to
pay more money and it's like if I just
saved all the money that I made I could
probably be a billionaire you know so
you make a lot of money but you spend it
on drugs and hotel rooms yeah mmhmm yeah
yeah
and it's crazy out there in the streets
like you definitely don't want to be out
there like between the cops and the
people like they're both all bad uh-huh
like so yeah I getting a room is like
necessary yeah like you have to have a
room and you can't like live off with
somebody else you know like so you're
living in hotel rooms yeah just going
from you yeah yeah they use it to bring
clients as well as mm-hmm a place to
sleep yeah mm-hmm yeah what do you what
do you you could have anything what do
you wish could come into your life yeah
I'll ask that again I can edit this
together sorry about that so if you
could get a lucky break
like if something great could happen for
you what what would you like that to be
the lottery would be awesome vacation
would be awesome
if you probably use a break from all
this right yeah definitely I mean it's
been going on for so long you know it's
kind of hard to remember what it's like
not with it in my life you know all
right Briana thank you so much for
talking with me you're welcome good luck
with getting back with your your son
thank you
okay
you